bonsoir diagonale l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs de retour
pour cette année 2011 ce nouveau
millénaire et loi la pêche parce que
beaucoup beaucoup d'événements se
termine et démarre beaucoup d'événements
se termine bon tout d'abord bonne année
à tous effectivement puisque c'est la
grande rentrée celle en 2001 qui
commence et échiquéenne mans c'est tout
à fait au point puisque donc il ya déjà
la fin de ce championnat du monde dont
on avait fait nombreux spéciale est
également plein d'événements qui
commence stephen peine l1 qui commence
alors on va tout de suite sur place du
monde en avait dit que effectivement à
priori ça devrait être ça devait être
jouée après trois parties puisque annan
avait déjà gagné 2-0 et ça s'est pas
démenti puisque chez rough a pris une
troisième bull d'affilée oui directement
dans la continuité il s'est fait
proprement massacré wichmann un an
d'après le centre dans une française il
a tenu comme un fou ne laissant aucune
chance à shirov qui est sacrifié une
pièce puis une deuxième
bref rien est arrivé à nantes a gagné
trois et demi 1/2 shirov n'a tiré qu'une
seule nul dans ce match c'est une
véritable explosion une explosion morts
il faut signaler que cramique a commenté
d'ailleurs ce championnat du monde
il signe que la nand et le vainqueur
normal de ceux de ce championnat et que
chez rough était probablement un peu en
dessous de son niveau habituel sur ce
tournoi mais il a quand même au final
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal à noter
quand même au passage que shirov a perdu
des points d'eau en stand donc on peut
être vice-champion du monde et perdre
des points rouges c'est c'est une
remarque un petit peu surprenante
en tout cas bravo attendent est ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que là ça devient très
compliqué puisqu'on a donc annoncé
champion du monde
a priori quand même assez légitime on ne
pourra pas dire comme on disait avec
kalichman que c'est un coup de bol
c'est difficile parce que c'était le
favori il a gagné le tournoi en serbie
sont pas laissés surprendre
oui et de l'autre côté dans ma chronique
qui a battu kasparov bon mais qui est
bon il ya le problème alors c'est plus
compliqué que ça stéphane puisqu'il faut
faire également intervenir
kasparov et shirov là dedans alors donc
nous avons kasparov qui bat anand mais
qui perd contre kramnik chronique qui
bat kasparov
mais qui perd contre shirov et shirov
qui battra munich mais qui perd contre
allende
bref lequel des quatre échantillons en
tout cas ils ont tous perdu au moins un
match dans leur vie donc pour l'instant
c'est le flou le plus total
alors voilà ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
l'idéal c'est qu'il ya un match organisé
entre kramnik est un homme pour mettre
les choses au point
bon le problème c'est aussi le
changement de formule
il ya un match organisé entre chronique
et annonce ça serait l'idéal ça serait
idéal c dans l'air et ils sont en train
d'envisager un match de prestige est dir
est mais bon tout le monde sait que ce
que ce que ça voudrait dire mais par
contre bon effectivement après laquelle
la vraie question en fait ce que
l'application que posco expérience c'est
pas tellement de savoir qui est le plus
fort c'est de savoir comment définit le
championnat du monde ce que si c'est le
système fi des cas au bout d'un mois où
est-ce qu'on revient un système avec un
match à la fin qui est quand même a
priori plus les plus médiatiques en tout
cas on leur dit mieux enfin bon même
sens en parler au niveau médias je ne
sais pas qui est la forme de la plus
juste on pourrait peut-être en isère un
tournoi quadruples ronde avec ces quatre
joueurs en même temps intéressants
d'autres problèmes mais c'est pas
évident est ce que ce n'est pas le même
style de jeu aussi quelqu'un bat l'autre
4 0 tout de suite ça fausse le tournoi
je pense qu'il ya pas de solution de
toute façon ces quatre très bons joueurs
qui sont en tête mais même en boxe
stéphane on sait qui est championne du
monde dont on sait pas qui est le
meilleur boxeur c'est toujours pareil
oui voilà bon alors donc bref un angle
championne du monde fis des cramique
champion du monde
kasparov on va dire games et puis donc
début 2001 alors le match actuelle qui
nous intéresse dont on va parler
aujourd'hui c'est un match entre kramnik
et l'écossé la première sortie de
kramnik en tant que champion du monde
on va y revenir tout de suite et ensuite
en janvier on ya le super tournoi qui va
peut-être mettre les choses au point
le tournoi des 15 et où les dix
meilleurs joueurs mondiaux sont là donc
kasparov kramnik canarder shirov donc ça
va ça va sûrement chauffer et on va
aller là bas fait un reportage spécial
oui tout à fait on vous ramènera des
images donc fin janvier puisque le
tournoi commence le 12 janvier pour être
précis et finit le 28
donc on ira en cours de tournoi 1000 de
tournois ce qui fait que fin janvier
vous aurez un reportage en images alors
ça va être extrêmement chaud puisque il
y en a qu'on a tendance à oublier dans
cette période c'est quand même kasparov
et kasparov qui n'a pas joué depuis sa
défaite contre cramique qui doit se
préparer se prépare et se préparer et
qui va arriver vraisemblablement en
super forme et en tout cas prêt à en
découdre
et puis bon il faut pas oublier les
outsideurs parce qu'on sait pas ce qu'il
te sortir de là ils vont a priori ça
devrait pas échapper la victoire et
devrait pas échapper à ces quatre là oui
très difficile alors par contre à leur
première sortie de cramique en tant que
champion du monde ça c'est intéressant
alors c'est un match
de prestige c'est pas un match officiel
dont ceux des parties rapides mais bon
kramnik joue contre eux peter rico dans
son match annuel je dirais presque
standard quoi oui c'est dire qu'on peut
pas vraiment dire stéphane que c'est un
match de prestige à partie un moment où
il ya le champion du monde quand il est
là il remet d'une certaine manière son
titre en jeu psychologiquement en tout
cas aux yeux du monde et chez tient donc
la trame ni contre peter l'écho ce n'est
pas un adversaire facile pitt art déco
le jeune hongrois puisqu'on sait qu'il
est systématiquement dans les cinq six
meilleurs joueurs du monde
il vient juste après ce bloc de 4 ouais
donc il est extrêmement fort en semi
rapide il joue pas mal non plus c'est un
des joueurs les plus solides qui
existent donc ça donne il aimait
d'accueil un chalenge kasparov ils
avaient battu les stars sur une partie
semi rapide
à francfort la francfort exactement
avant d'être enfin après avoir été
gagnant dans la première partie
donc il a battu kasparov ans merapi
c'est pas mal alors il avait battu
l'année dernière dans ce même match qui
il ya une société allemande qui
sponsorise les courses pour ceux qui
amassent chaque année il avait battu
l'année dernière le champion du monde
fis des qualifs man mais cette fois il
s'attaque aux champions du monde
rejoignent games à noter qui s'est fait
éliminer aux championnats du monde fis
départ kalichman en décembre mais bon il
est tombé malade un fait un oui alors ça
c'est ce qu'on a dit après le tournoi
bon c'était prenant au frais pendant mes
deco avait vraisemblement pas envie d'en
parler pendant le tournoi ça se comprend
effectivement c'était quand même un
match marathon qui a duré très longtemps
puisqu'il ya eu une longue série des
partages
on est encore beaucoup de nuls et
c'était en mort subite qu'elle ait fana
a fini par remporter une partie
l'écho a été éliminée de ce champion du
monde mais maintenant contre cramique
nouveau challenge parties rapides
c'est intéressant et d'ailleurs le match
tient ses promesses
le match entre ses promesses alors on a
cru que ça allait finalement se pas se
faire que d'un côté puisque au bout de
quatre parties crâne ligne mené 2 0 2
victoires et 2 nuls 2-0 et arrive la
cinquième partie et les corps viens on
va revenir dans le match oui alors
peut-être on va détailler un peu plus
ses quatre premières parties première
partie amicale et blanc les coaches
london fade et se fait tout simplement
pulvérisé
donc ça rappelle un peu kasparov tente
une grande fête le championnat du monde
qui se fait massacrer qu'il large au
plus après effectivement les cônes là
partout et ça c'est une première en
arguant cramique une fois de plus la
bonne fin d'année c'est une fois on
s'est fait massacrer on arrête
ensuite les qu avec les blancs 9
rien contre stéphane la berlinoise quand
même dit que la fao oublier joe la
berlinoise lie donc qu'il rejoue la
l'ouverture anti caspar ans donc ça veut
dire que il va sûrement utiliser de
cette année et peut-être encore contre
kasparov habana et apparemment il a
trouvé une formule qui lui plaît
puisqu'il fait nul facilement dans la
première et il remporte la 2ème
berlinoise donc je gagne une partie avec
les noirs les co ayant été un petit peu
dans le doute un petit peu dans le flou
ne sachant pas trop quoi faire d'une
ouverture hésite en plein devenir
chronique lui n'a pas eu de problème il
a son plan il a exécuté
donc bref après quatre parties devient
pour krainik deux nuls
ça semblait vraiment facile pour
vladimir qui allait enchaîner une fois
de plus avec les blancs dans la
cinquième et là c'est là que les fonds
se réveille dans sa machine combien de
partis à 8 c 8 ou 6 non c'est en 12
parties ces douze pardon 12 parties
semi-rapides ainsi jour 6 jours et deux
parties par aujourd'hui étant le jour de
repos
voilà donc alors on va voir cette
cinquième partie dont ce qui prouve que
finalement il va ça va pas être facile
que ça pour kramnik on a eu peur quand
même que ce match soit une démonstration
donc on va passer à cette cinquième
partie entre cramique donc champion du
monde bat games et peter l'écho voilà
tout de suite ça va arriver
alors voilà donc cavalier f3 le coup
préféré de bladinières krainik oui alors
nous allons donc passer en axant station
à droite de l'échiquier
ces cinq c4 donc là ça rappelle un peu
la dernière partie kasparov
granic alors que stéphane est arrivé
voilà il viendrait en petit à droite
qu'elle est une anglaise au symétrique
stéphane et la guitare les coujoux le
coup hausse est aussi à noter que
normalement eh bien on joue plutôt le
coup qu'elle ait des huit ans et six
monarques également g3 ça c'est un fou
ancien ghetto on a déjà vu ça des six
réaction contre ce fou voilà cercle fous
ces 8 va venir sur la case bessette et
s'opposer sur cette diagonale blanche à
la sortie du four blanc sur lequel des
deux fous j'ai deux options possibles
foulée cette petit rock
maintenant les noirs que font-ils et
bien elle continue à sortir leurs pièces
et c'est important dans l'ouverture elle
je vous fous aux 7 avec l'idée de faire
le petit rock tout simplement maintenant
et plusieurs plans pour l'élan dans
cette position stéphane qui sont tous
très intéressants par exemple on peut
jouer une véritable anglaise en temps le
coût des deux des trois cantines
véritable anglaise ça veut dire qu'on
aura cette structure la fameuse
structure du dragon qui est celle là qui
fait un peu semble-t-il cancer un dragon
ça veut dire qu'on laissera le pion des
sur la case d3 sympathie et ensuite on
va jouer tour b 1 à 3 et b4 on va
commencer notre contre je surfe un autre
jeu plutôt sur le carreau gisèle dama là
ça serait normal maintenant cram nick a
une autre idée
il prend le centre quand même et ça a
priori on peut pas dire que ce soit une
mauvaise conception puis ce conseil dans
les ouvertures il faut prendre le centre
anti femmes tout à fait donc la leko ça
crée une menace directe au passage
ouais la glace est évidemment de jouer
des quatre des cinq qui boucherait le
fou de cette boucherie le fou 17 qui
prendrait de l'espace et ça serait
terrible
les noirs sont donc normalement objet de
prendre au centre là on peut reprendre
du cavalier mais ça changerait les fous
nous faut bessette contre le sujet de
chronique a pas envie de simplifier la
position pour l'instant où tout d'un
prends des cachets à faiblir un peu le
roi blanc oui mais oui c'est ça de
blessés légers
mais le principal étant surtout la
simplification d'un prend des caps par
contre c'est donc ça évite des changes
des fous mais c'est un énorme
retour un énorme énorme c'est un
désavantage c'est perdre a été la pause
et 56 faut jamais sortir la dame trop
tôt puisque là tout de suite les coûts
en profite
il sort son cavalier sur la casse et six
attaquants la dame dont ils gagnent en
quittant gagne un temps puisque la lame
et objets de reboucher et en plus on
voit pas de la bonne case pour cette
dame donc oui bien sûr la case f4f qui
attend une case pas très joli on va pas
rappelle une peur qui te graver nicholas
pard enfin oui tout à fait dans cette
partie là s'il en avait trop dit synares
c'est la partie dinars est énorme au
champion du monde champion du monde
cette veine là je crois la 12e partie où
la 14e c'était humide et dernière partie
entre amis qui avaient les blancs et ils
avaient souffert dans cette partie ici
il avait réussi mais tellement acheter
parce que qu'est ce qu'on fait à
l'époque alphonsus est née c'est un peu
différent ou petit rock tour d un don
qu'est ce qui se passe dans cette
position si les noirs arrivent à jouer
17 des 5
il y aura des échanges au centre et la
position sera égale oui une chronique ne
veut pas permettre ça bien entendu les
blancs doivent essayer de garder au
maximum le plus longtemps possible à
leur avantage de développement et
surtout il faut étouffer des noirs il
faut faire ce qu'on appelle un étau de
maroc si ces termes être influencés cap
et éventuellement un autre angle 4 tenir
le centre et essayé de presser les noirs
dire de les cantonner sur une deux ou
trois rangées voilà et ne pas les
laisser sortir de leur regard des quatre
ans j'ai pour soi et quand on est noir
3ème débite donc la propre aux échanges
des dames est tout à fait mais en fait
crave ni que ce qu'indique s'en fout on
s'en fout c'est à dire que ils
n'échangent pas les dames il n'évite pas
les changer d'âme il joue simplement un
bon koup
il joue le coup eux deux quatre qu'outil
dont convoi blindé complètement la casse
des 5 ce qui veut donc dire que les
noirs ne pourront pas vraiment joué 17
des cinq le coût qui les auraient libéré
mais en même temps il permet l'échangé
dame
que les comptes ne fait pas alors le
coup ne fait pas ce qu'on dit souvent
c'est que c'est bien de ramener un point
vers le centre sert si la leko échange
les dames
oui évidemment on prend des tokio
probablement non c'est pas évident
c'était une super vision du tout d'un
progrès à faire et que pions oui c'est
intéressant on prendra une option ça ça
comme des conséquences c'est que ça fait
lui elle ce retour de pure ouais mais il
ya plus de pions vers le centre
peut-être moi je sais pas peut-être il
faut prendre un peu fou avec le fou ça a
l'air assez logique quand même dans la
mesure où on va peut-être pouvoir le
mettre sur la case des 6 m le kenyan b5
profité de l'affaiblissement des cases
noires ouais ça m'a l'air d'être plus
que dans l'esprit plus dans l'esprit
tout à fait donc 4 les connais change
pas les dames probablement à cause de
fou prend et qui avait 5
il joue le coup 17 des 6 et maintenant
on est complètement dans ce qu'on
appelle le hérisson stéphane alors
pourquoi le ver eecke sont alors là
qu'est ce que c'est le herissier
hippiques hippiques
et puis donc la lorraine pic c'est cette
formation on va la voir dans un instant
ça va devenir chronique tout b2 b3
pourquoi pas et la déco joie si ce seuil
la c'est un hérisson c'est un hérisson
voilà l an le hérisson c'est ça donc
après le dragon vous avez le verizon
voilà c'est normal donc structure
hérisson c'est à dire qu'à tout moment
les noirs peuvent jouer soit 2,5
déjà on va montrer ce qu'ils contrôlent
à dessein qui contrôlera tout ça c'est
contrôler c'est comme des pics en fait
mal en fait c'est ça donc c'est les
piqûres ils sont le hérisson empêche les
blancs complètement d'aller sur cette
quatrième rangée
l'objectif des noirs dans cette position
ça va être de préparer
donc là on va enlever on va enlever tout
ça c'est de préparer la vence mais c'est
compliqué il y en a beaucoup mais vous
voyez le hérisson c'est ça ça pique
c'est de préparer avant soit du cube et
en b 5 soit du pion des andes et 5
alors ça paraît curieux parce que ils
vont pas le jouer tout de suite
ils vont attendre longtemps et pourtant
il semblerait que les blancs malgré le
fait qu'ils aient plus d espace n'est
pas de plan n'est pas d'emplacement pour
leur pièce pour empêcher la poussée
efficace du plan b ou du plan d donc
c'est très très curieux comme formation
ouais mais on dit souvent aussi quand
même avec le les taux de marc auxi que
c'est bien ça le problème c'est que les
blancs peuvent pas trop bouger aussi oui
voilà les noirs ne peuvent pas bouger
mais les blancs non plus puisque la
truite arc en ciel mouche de ça
affaiblit tout de suite tout à fait
alors les blancs tous les coups de pions
des blancs sont très responsables dans
cette position il faut il faire très
attention
alors en voyant cette partie pendant le
direct j'étais très curieux de savoir
comment kramnik allait jouer
effectivement il n'a pas été convaincant
mais c'est très délicat à jouer pour les
blancs alors il commence par chaque
foulée deux bon pourquoi pas en marie
logis oui normalement on n'aime pas
mettre trop le fou sur cette grande
diagonale
parce que les noirs très souvent je le
cou aux six ou 5 1 qui bouchent le coup
et aka structure des six simples four b2
se retrouvent momentanément hors course
ouais donc bon cb2 on peut pas encore
reproché ce coup mais ce n'est pas
forcément le meilleur emplacement
peter découvre place ces pièces d'hab
c'est cette dame c'est cette donc
probablement là il va placer pièces dont
ne soit commencée puisque les semi
ouverte pour lui avec le plein peut-être
à terme donc toujours pareil de jouer
soit décider scène sarah bessie smith
and will lead mc 7 pour l'instant c'est
de mettre une tour sur la colonne c'est
stéphane latour à 8 ans évite de mettre
de la puissance là sur cette colonne
ensuite on va mettre la tour f 8 sur la
case 1,8 et ensuite on va rapatrier nos
pièces sur des bonnes cases mais on va
voir parce que la façon dont l'écho a
joué très très classique très
conventionnel et c est apparemment très
fort de ses 7 h trois chroniques c'est
pas trop où aller puisqu'il a pas de
levier pion à proprement parler il peut
pas percer l'un pour l'instant pour
avancer vite
voilà donc pour l'instant et quoi encore
des coups bas les blanches ivoire il
pourrait jouer tour assez invisible
oui mais tu auras sait bien qu est-ce
que sa préférence était sacré pas rien
ça développe la pièce oui c'est un joli
coup mais on va là qu'elle est là il
faut voir il faut faire un plan un
actuel voilà c'est ça c'est que même si
on peut pas se fiancer ne peut pas
avancer
il est contrôlé la case c'est simple on
peut le montrer donc même si on met une
tour derrière ça sert à rien derrière ce
pion puisque la casse et 5 est contrôlé
par deux purs noir donc deux points
noirs et quand même pas mal de pièces
aussi dans l'ipad allait tout donc on va
pas trop c'est une case sait on peut pas
on ne peut rien faire donc le pion doit
rester un c4 donc du coup effectivement
mettre une tour derrière même si ça
semble naturel c'est pas efficace ça
serait mieux
défensive tout simplement unique a paru
durer comme ça et le jeu des mots cette
dame 3 9 à 3 bon mais un oeil sur
l'option b 6 on ne sait jamais oui à
noter que ça peut être une faiblesse
oui mais c'est toujours très simple les
noirs de défendre en jouant cavalier 617
s'était fait à priori pour l'instant pas
vraiment d'idée la dame était mal placé
en f4 c'est tout ce qu'on peut dire il
la replace en de trois cavaliers ou cinq
donc la responsable ou l écho la promo
effectivement puisque les blues
pourraient échanger avec les noirs qui
reprendrait du pion alors on va on va
envisager puisque c'est c'est un coup
critique c'est très important de
comprendre ce qui se passe après
qu'avait des grands cavaliers
pourquoi on dit que ces critiques tout
simplement parce que ça change la
structure de pions oui c'est très un
voilà il faut reprendre du pian ça fait
moins de bruit et en plus ça c'est un
pur doublé pour les noirs mais alors
qu'est ce qu'on voit maintenant si on
regarde d'un peu plus près on voit que
le foot c'est de voir venir en c5 avec
ton très belle diagonale l'a peut-être
même en d4
mais parce que nos soeurs à la casse des
quatre qui est forte mais il ya le pion
f2 aussi que foot ap ce pion et mine de
rien je ne veux c'est pas forcément le
plus important mais il ya les requêtes
aussi qu'ils en pensent ouais mais ça
empêchera les pions de se protéger
longtemps enfin c'est embêtant quoi
c'est embêtant et les noirs obtiendrez
un jeu très dynamique
on peut même envisager par exemple la
manoeuvre la manoeuvre touré fuite suivi
de tour des quatre ça c'est possible
c'est un plan également en ferrain ce
qui rend les 5es par al même si les deux
labels et il contrôle bien la casse des
quatre et c'est bon pour les noirs
surtout on voit ici que les pièces des
noirs sont plus actifs mais sont plus
actifs dans la mesure où blanc par
exemple est hors jeu
bloqué par son propre piège 4 donc quand
vous voyez cabello 5 si vous avez et non
dans cette position est bien
ne le prenez pas ce serait une faute
positionnelle chronique joue cavalier
des quatre banques et à et par contre
ils menacent peut-être de jouer f2f 4
peut-être oui alors évidemment la relève
de f4 à chasseral be made you ça voilà
mais ça affaiblit les blancs en veut un
insert que le roi blanc va se retrouver
un peu à l'air le feu qui ont f qui
avance toujours trop tôt fabrice jamais
assez quelle est l'idée du dernier coup
de crâne qui vient de jouer cavalier en
d4
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils de mélasse des
femmes c'est pour contrôler la case des
ils empêchent les normes a joué les six
bessalah il veut pas que ce coup puisse
être ne serait ce qu'envisager par
hôpital est donc pour l'instant
chronique joue un peu en ils empêchent
les noirs d'exécuter leur plan
à défaut d'avoir lui-même en plan alors
là au 16e coup les causes ou h6 en corse
à son cou quad attentes
c'est un coude a tenté un coup typique
du hérisson bon de faire un coucou
tranquille quoi ont-ils de trois ans
puisque ça a fait la petite saynète pour
le roi c'est toujours le cas là
effectivement a priori rien ne presse
puisque les noirs sont bien quand on est
dans leur camp bien c'est bien solide et
c'est un coup préventif aussi parce
qu'on peut dire qu'un des plans des
blancs c'est pousser plongé de 3,4 la
sociale pour chasser ce cavalier si
c'est le cas il ya 6
il est un peu fou et 7 ensuite jouer
lâche 4 donc ce couac si c'est pas mal
parce qu'ils contrôlent laquelle j'ai
cinq ans en avance un accord intéressant
tour d2 bon bon pourquoi pour la bonne
réplique et ce genre de coups un nom
alors on peut l'expliquer facilement
kramnik est prévu de mettre ses tours
sur les colonnes d et f
voici son plan il veut mettre des tours
sur ses 2 colonnes là alors qu'est ce
qui est idéal dans cette position si on
la regarde bien il peut jouer tour f1
suite en d1
ce qui prend de temps et qui mettra les
tours sur sedo case là maintenant avec
son coup tours d2 au coup d'après s'il
joue tour f1 on verra que ça aura pris
d'autant également les tours sont sur
ces deux cas cela ce qui est plus souple
on pourquoi parce que on peut facilement
doubler les tours ensuite voilà ils sont
prêts à se mettre une barrière lot pour
bien contrôler une colonie voilà
exactement qui s'ouvre on sera prêts à
doubler les tours donc ça gagne entre
guillemets un temps on est malgré le
montant potentiellement même si c'est
pas forcément important tour eiffe vite
ça c'est bien joué
au rayon x 1,7 et femmes voilà sept
tours peu voilà sur quoi les noirs
pourrait avoir des idées de jouer des 5
par exemple maintenant oui des 5 tout à
fait là c'est vraiment à l'ordre du jour
des cinq sens que là il ya beaucoup de
choses qui s'ouvre et la dame serait
attaquée par la tour 8
on pourrait sacrifier des choses et ça
pourrait marcher alors pour l'instant ce
n'est pas encore d'actualité dans la
mesure où il ya trop de pièces qui
dérangent la colonne ou encore des pieds
de les attentions mais si elles portent
tous un potentiel ça se dégage plus vite
mais elle veut qu'on ne le pense
vladimir kramnik jour où alain roche
s'est pas trop quoi faire et ça c'est
vraiment le coup alors ce qu'en disait
il a peut-être pas envie de jouer 4
parce que ça affaiblit la diagonale vers
le roi oui oui de nos jeux j'observais
des pièces bleus voilà qui sont donc
redevenu noir ces lieux ouache un
cavalier e en 17 samedi date encore non
alors ça ne va pas du tout alors
justement attention on dirait un kodak
c'est un coup très important stéphane à
pourquoi vient on replace ce cavalier
alors rappelons que ce cavalier vient de
la case c6 pas facile à quoi docteur en
échange il est venu à eux cinq ans
maintenant il revient aux 17es ou
va-t-il est bien de va vers cette classe
c 5
voilà le plan voilà et donc à partir de
ces simples on aura trois pièces qui
attaquent le pian pilonnent le pian au
carvi tu en es 4,1 on le voit donc ça
c'est encore désagréable et en plus
après ça soutient la percée des six des
5 de façon très efficace
vladimir kramnik fait f4 il faut quand
même qu'ils fassent des coups on enlève
voilà et joseph k donc ça explique un
peu le courage 1 il n'y a pas de l'eau
il n'y a pas de possibilité pour les
noirs de faire un clouage dam d'un
miroir oui tout à fait être quatre ici
donc c'est difficile
suite alors faut et suite de l'écho
alors un coup tranquille mais ça libère
la tour voilà milliers là on voit que
c'est un langage c'est là que la lame
les noirs on as probablement de jouer
deux des cinq dessins qui à leur
retraite spatialement en fait ils
menacent pas mon va expliquer pourquoi
kramix autour f1 tout répond alors là
depuis le temps qu'on le dit il
semblerait que toutes les conditions
soient réunies pour un dessin crise n'a
pas l'air bon ben si orelsan tout
simplement alors pas tout de suite
stéphane tête voilà ans ici on prend
d'abord peut-être en dessin qui ont su
pas sûr donc de 5
nous sommes tout de suite à leur banc le
5 ça fait très peu puisque la le khalife
si cette attaque et là pas de case oui
oui ok elle avait peu pâle 1,17 tout de
suite donc certes il y en a sept ou 1,5
et bien tout simplement ça à faire le
clown en plus ça perd le plan des cinq
mais en plus comme à le placer en plus
il serait mal placé au même prix donc
ici après tout la fin il n'y a pas de
il n'y a pas de menace les noirs peuvent
pas jouer des 5 il joue donc peter les
coûts d'amd vite
encore un coup qui n'a l'air de rien
alors demandez vite alors ça c'est cool
c'est le coup mal à ce genre
d'opposition parce que tu avais une bon
ça libère la tour c 8
ça libère l'action à tour ses huit ça
peut être utile mais surtout ses potes
ça peut aider pour pousser de b6 b5
oui tout à fait alors on voit beaucoup
de rayons x voilà sept tours 1,8
il va peut-être mettre le flanc à 8
l'écho au rite aid plus tard le foot des
7 vallées 1 à 8
et la dame pourra soutenir l'avancée du
pinot noir voilà ce qui va pouvoir
attaquer la chaîne des puys ans et le
respect c'est d'autant plus que la dame
on sait cette était pas spécialement
bien placé puisque il vaut mieux avoir
une tour sur une colonne ouverte wind ça
c'est un petit coup mais en fait c'est
une toutes les techniques de placement
sont ceux retrouvés sont faciles à sohar
se rappeler et sont en général bonnes
dans ce type de position et c'est
extrêmement connue c'est extrêmement
connu un des premiers à mettre ce
système à la mode c'était bobby fischer
stéphane qui a gagné beaucoup beaucoup
de partis au fond des hérissons et donc
savait à l'époque un peu choqué de jouer
comme ça sur trois rangées de loin ça
marche un peu à la meinau beach koala
une hyper moderne l hyper moderne g4g 4
alors ça c'est un coup aux responsables
mais ils voient que s'il fait rien
grammy qui voit qu'il va se prendre des
sites bilingues ou des six des cinq plus
tard
voyez les noirs vont avoir leur
potentiel de pièces qui va se libérer
donc il se dit bon faut essayer de faire
quelque chose pour avoir du contre-jour
a noté stéphane dans cette question le
gros problème des blancs c'est qu'ils
ont beaucoup plus de territoire à tenir
et que donc effectivement dès que le jeu
s'ouvre et bien les pièces noires ballet
de tous les profils des deux côtés les
noirs ont peu de place pour vous pour
nous émerveiller alors évidemment le
revers de la médaille c'est que si les
noirs n'arrive pas à ouvrir le jeu et
bien tout simplement ils vont se faire
étouffer comme dans un sac plastique là
g4 bon pourquoi pas peter les coups
alors oui dans la salle ça commence à
être chaud quoi la menace peut-être g5
recruté au fc d'hôpital et qu est plus
protégé du tout ouais donc ce par le roi
par le roi que par le roi oui mais s'il
ya une tour qui commence avec dessus
c'est désagréable
[ __ ] les coujoux km à 10h 7/4 et h7
pas ça alors ça dure expliquer ça alors
ça prévient gsm 2g cents cavaliers pas
attaqué oui presque les banques ne
pourraient pas quand même joué g5 1 ou
alors je sens que ça a pas l'air
extraordinaires dans la mesure où après
j'ai 5 puis on prend chez 5 des vendeurs
et probablement il faudrait reprendre du
pillon ce qui est loin d'une tour du
centre et ça permettrait peut-être
l'heure de revenir au racing
tout à fait voilà bah casse de cinq
seraient libérés ce qu il serait très
bien
donc là haut niveau structure de pions
les noirs sont mieux puisqu'ils ont deux
blocs et les blancs en ont trois voire
appelé on va compter les blocs des
blancs mais il y en a un là irruption
tout seul on compte donc comme un bloc
et là il ya un bloc de 2 donc 2 contre
trop 3,3 pour les blancs deux contre
deux pour les noirs c'est mieux pour les
noirs ou les pièces noires sont assez
bonnes assez efficace c'est assez bien
placé sauf le câblage c'était peut-être
un peu mais bon une tape sur gsm quand
même donc ici probablement légère avant
tellement qu'elle dit h7 prévient g5
vladimir kramnik tour des en f2 voilà ça
c'est le signe d'une attaque vers le roi
blanc vers le roi noir et la unique
on se dit qu'il a pas toi en revenir
parce que il a quand même le fils b 2
qui peut se réveiller un qui peut
attaquer le roi les deux tours qui sont
en position
ici il va falloir qu'il joue la percée
f4 f5 la dîmière pour essayer d'attaquer
leur en noir c'est chaud c'est chaud
parce que f4 f5 même une fois qu'on l'a
joué et bien
sa menace toujours rien stefan sahm
nasri blanc d'ailleurs peter des groupes
jouent faux à 8 tranquille vas-y joue il
n'a pas peur ouais bah non mais c'est
lui qui prépare pour l'instant mais il
peut pas condamner un problème pourquoi
pas si les deux quarts à les protéger de
qui allait prendre et le pian et après
les cavaliers prendrait mais il peut
menacer peut-être aux cinq salaire de 5
c'est délicat vision bien d'exception
bougez vous qui avez des 4,5 alors une
remarque sur cette variante 1 des clés
noires rouges les caraïbes l'on y entre
ouais on indiquait de l'an bouge les
pions noirs avancent ouais c'est ça bref
c'est l'équipe de la terreur à bouger il
faut pas bouger une fois pas bougé
d'alger 3 lames g3 intéressant la dame
s'en va de cette colonne mais et et
ouais on voit qu'elle le soutient les
pions à peut-être les blancs vont jouer
h 3 h 4 oui suivi de jets que j'ai eus
cas de gestion tout effet quel revers de
la médaille le cas les d4 n'est plus
protégé et peter les coûts en profite
tout de suite à avec le coup j'essaie de
g6 voilà idée le fou vient angers cet
attaquant le foot gay le quartier des
cartes attaque le cahier des 4 et 6 qui
va les bouches et b5 et dessins kieboom
ça y est et là ça y est ils se libèrent
égaux et avec une pression et c'est
l'explosion c'est une explosion c'est
l'explosion m'a dit mercredi que joe
f500 tant que ça commence à tourner au
vinaigre le salaire bon quand même une
9-5 parce que bon et bien on va quand
même que les tours vont s'ouvrir
oui sur la et puis que laurent noir et
l'arrière donc ça a l'air quand même
dangereux la menace positionnelle de skf
5 c'est sans doute de jouer f6 stéphane
boucher les noirs c'est effectivement ça
a l'air curieux d'avoir mis les deux
tours comme ça
une fois qu'on a installé un pion f6 et
bien le cavalier h7 très mal placé 1
nous faut et fuite très mal placée aussi
bref ces deux pièces noires seraient
hors jeu ouais le roi noir faible avis
donc la menace positionnelle c'est de
justice mais là juste à temps fou j'ai
cette bougie cette voie là parce que
juste avant on faisait psy on prenait
d'un cavalier évidemment on sacrifie une
tour pour 2k mali oui c'est toujours
bien oui là on peut plus il ya quand
même trois pièces qui protège 1 à 3
sièges des deux tours contre lequel
fondera des années de temps faut tout ça
mais ça fait beaucoup
ce qui est beaucoup moins bien alors là
ça y est c'est à partir de ce moment là
on peut dire que les noirs sont déjà
mieux un tout petit peu mieux m à noter
que le nom section carrée les d4
qu'attaquer et y'a pas moyen de le
défendre efficacement n'ont pas moyen
non il n'y a pas de ya pas de solution
parce qu'il ya un autre problème aussi
stéphane c'est qu'il ya le coup 1.951
régulièrement avec l'option ou quatre
qui va se retrouver attaquer et par deux
fois huit
ouais et par la tour élite ce cavalier
hachette qui peut sauter sur la 4g 5 ce
qui a aidé cette qui peut sauter sur la
case c5
ça fait beaucoup de flash mais on sent
que la position noir peut se desserrer
comme un ressort à se déplier que se
déplier comme un ressort et exploser
donc à la gueule des blondes
wey kaw les ce2 qu'elle essaie odom la
bougie ce cavaliere a plus bougé lors
qu'il ne bougeait celui-là il est la
déesse le plus avancé est finalement
donc inconvénients stéphane le câliner
plus en c3 donc c'est tout de suite on
pense à deux choses première chose le
coupé cette dernière réussit tout de
suite deuxième chose le pion aux quatre
moines protéger les moins protégés
d'éric bouger l'autre cavaliers ce
n'était pas tout à fait pareil ce
n'était pas tout à fait pareil sa
protégée ou quatre mais là c'était donc
la laisser cinq critères locaux en
profitent car il sait c'est votre effort
known as le pied en quatre ou simplement
cavalli prend points 4 avec un gain
technique un gain trieux le roi blanc
faible quand même en a eu des rois blanc
comment cette faiblesse zaoui j'aurais
donné le fou au fait c'est horrible très
très délicat ou pas il faut pas gérer un
problème alors le coup en vidéo et c'est
de défendre ses pions oui enfin bon on
peut contre attaquer tout de suite déjà
quand même alors non mais dans un
premier temps on va envisager les
défenses possible du pion aux quatre oui
alors quelles sont elles dames 3 par
exemple des mots 300 et une dame e3
vraiment sur des secours protégez moi
l'un de vous trois possibilités pour
deux fonctions mais là il ya eu prend f5
qu'est ce qui se passe on voit la
thyroïde qui se réveille c'est horrible
contrôle à 2003 mais évidemment l'option
de 4 est attaqué il est perdu il est
perdu est perdu il est perdu c'est
terminé c'est pas possible de 3 c'est
pas possible ça marche pas donc après
qu'elle et ses 5 un autre coup possible
aurait été d'un f4
c'est une sanction terrible ça perd tout
de suite ya eu 500 fourchette fourche
adam et cavaliers attaque et la dame et
le sapin d'une pièce et en plus les
toros liberia c'est une pièce sais pas
c'est donc pas viable non plus on voit
pas d'autres coins surtout avec 4 même
punition une affichette blanche un autre
il ya d'autres possibilités
on ne peut plus défendre le pion au gatt
à partir de cette position est vraiment
qu'ils essaient 3 c'est possible ou plus
mais qui est des quatre ans prises oui
donc la trame n'est que joue un coup
intermédiaire où pranger 6 voilà donc
ils cassent un peu
la structure durable en force france
puisque sa menace puis on prend deux
cavaliers avec échec avec des chèques
c'est important qu'on qu'il faut
reprendre et la mène maintenant il peut
faire d'un autre aura puisqu'il ya plus
qu on prend un f5 exactement ce qu'on
disait c'est ça la pointe c'est que la
tour au vide ne peut pas revenir en jeu
puisqu'il y aurait pour effet ce mois là
par contre là les noirs pourrait jouer
dès 5 ou c'est pas un chinois une chose
cette chose mais il pourrait peut-être
jouer des scènes pieds noirs à leur
dessein que d'abord c'est peut-être ça
soude des deux côtés ils peuvent le
faire mais c'est pas c'est pas clair on
va voir alors qu'est-ce qu'il a choisi
puis il a choisi quelque chose de plus
percutant plus solide plus percutant
voilà le 5e 5 ce qu'elle ait des cartes
étaient bien placés étaient ennuyeux il
n'a pas beaucoup de gaz
il en a qu'une voie là puisqu'on voit
que s'il vient à f3 ce qui n'a pas été
joué maintenant il ya donc ça perdait de
son local s'abstenir de les prendre en
attaquant la tour en plus la tour qui
est enfermé stéphane elle est enfermée
faire c'est joli c'est géométriques
ouais ça vienne où tour à tour les
cavaliers mais avec un piano plus
réussite vous fait beaucoup lequel près
de 5 la seule case disponible en corse
et le groupe kbc de stephen donc c'est
pareil ça bien repoussé le cavalier mans
par contre ça crée un gros trou sur la
case des 5 juin c'est à dire que s'il
est blanc le temps de jouer car elle et
ses trois quarts il des scènes c'est pas
si mal
ba qui y seraient ils seraient même les
charmants mais sûrement mieux mais ils
ont peut-être pas le temps et non
puisque peter l'écho et là ils jouent
bessin olympique dans l'écho et la pico
joue b5 donc trouve son contre jeu très
vite la menace puis en france les cartes
que prince et qu'alexandre peut pas
reprendre avant la pause du fou les deux
qui seront prises par la dame
voilà voilà voilà il faut toujours voir
çà et là dans cette position très
délicate cramique gaff gaff gaff y fait
la faute
il craque il a joué si on prend qui ont
ils appréhendé cinq coups qui perd tout
simplement
il fallait jouer la valise et 3
probablement fait les défendre falaise
le cas les c3 et c3 avec une pointe avec
une pointe qui on va vous montrer voilà
surpris on prend ces 4 puis en transe et
4 on joue plus on prend ces quatre quand
même et sur dame prend 2 voilà il
la tourbe et un enfermement voilà l adam
et ça c'est joli nodari perdu la dame
est perdus c'est joli il attaque et
alors on voit qu'elle applique alors
quels sont les cases de la dame y en a
dans cette position une autre 4-5-6
bayal a passé 6 12
mais royal tout tout sans prise ces
trois là sont en prit soin par le
cavalier par l'autre ouais
ces trois là sont contrôlés également
l'adar la deuxième est évidemment tout
le reste qui est sur la colonne est
contrôlé par la tour ben ouais la dame
est prise c'est le beau piège oui ça
s'appelle un fou empoisonné un foisonner
en général en b2c le pion aux poses on
revoit l'image c'est un faux empoisonnée
c'est vraiment c'est un pion c'est un
fois on peut donner c'est dire que si la
dame vient prendre et bien moins
fermement
donc ça c'était possible pour chroniquer
et surtout il gardait de contreras casse
des 5 pourquoi il n'a pas joué sa
maladie chronique
alors pour première hypothèse évidemment
la plus plausible c'est qu'il est
envahie note
il n'a pas beaucoup de temps oui parce
que sa vie partisane et sert minutes un
temps sûrement évidemment et deuxième
chose ça lui plaisait pas dans la mesure
où après pions prend ses quatre pions
français 4 la structure des blancs
étaient affaiblies ouais donc si on se
base sur des facteurs positionnelle soit
4,85 à faible prix opus
bon là quand même la prise en b2 reste
en l'air ce qu'il faut bouger aucune des
pièces parce que dès qu'on bouge un
cavalier la dame peut prendre
oui après le séchage oui mais tout à
fait non mais il va falloir d'abord
pertes un train en jouant fou hein ouais
ou faux à 3 et après cavale et ses
doigts un flamand c'est l'ombre mais
tout à fait mais ici c'est est encore
tenable c'était encore jouable
c'est ça qu'il fallait faire après b5
rami qui a joué pions prend b5 et là ça
va aller très très vite impute alcoa vus
lapointe chaleco a vu la combine est la
combine est alors ce qu'il faut noter
c'est que le cac a laissé deux ici oui
ce cas rien ces deux il est sous la
menace de la tour s'est vite donc là les
cours trouvent l'idée
il faut éliminer le pion central fort
des blancs pv y trouve la solution
cavalli prend voilà cavalli prob puisque
avec une pointe stéphane c'est que sur
fou prend cavaliers qui a été joué et on
a l'impression que ça défend le cavalier
ouais en fait non non pas du tout ce que
le x 8 clou le fou aucun voilà c'est à
dire qu'on peut prendre le cavalier et
c'est la partie c'est la partie pour
concéder à être libre à la partie alors
que voilà il y aura échec coran on n'a
pas le droit de prendre la tour oui et
donc il ya échange de pièces mais des
noirs ont récupéré le pion aux quatre
centrales très exactement c'est
important en plus celle d'une tour en c2
qui est très active mais on va revoir ce
qui vient de se passer est ce que cette
tour attaque le four b2 et les noirs va
récupérer pour biesheim fait autant
revenons à stéphane à cette version là
après qu'elle ait procuré quatre tout de
suite à des menaces
on attaque la tour f 2 à oui on attaque
le cavaly ces deux ça fait bouger donc
tout simplement pas le choix non pas le
choix on est au dessus tout fonctionne
maintenant je tout repenser de il ya ce
fameux cloud âge mais il ya la tour qui
attaquent foulée 2 et l'option b 5
yvette récupérer ou alors par le pion
soi même ce cas là il faut d'abord
protéger le fou donc les noirs récupère
le clairement qu'ils vont gagner un pion
au final et en plus le roi blanc est
faible avec le rôle dans les faibles et
en blanc la majorité centrale d'options
noir osant contre zéro la zone qui
inventa les biomes passé et là ça
devient très chaud donc ici une
chronique à une position extrêmement
délicate probablement perdante
il joue qu'elle et ses 3 beaucoup alors
ça défend le fou d2 par la tour carrée
tous et en plus ce qu'est lancée trop on
le voit et c'est d'installer ce qu'on
appelle une blocs had voilà il faut
bloquer sur case blanche à cocher les
pieds-noirs l'avancé si on peut laisser
bloquer cette option sur les quinze des
6 7 5
on a des chances de tenir même si on
absolument
en revanche des questions commencent à
avancer ça devient très très difficile
pour prend tour à toronto pour prendre
tout reprendre hélas bien joué hôpital
etc on ne se presse pas d'aller
récupérer le pion b5 subtil et juca les
g5 d'abord périgée 5 voilà alors quel
gsm que ça met la pression sur quatre
oui ça venait de gagner directement
stéphane on peut montrer un par exemple
sur une faute si on prend 1,6
ben c'est vraiment prendre à un cadre
suivi de dessin ce serait terrible
cavalli provoqué ce viennent tout de
suite qui avec les enfants elle a des
scènes ça vient tout de suite puisque si
lecavalier bouge et bien aujourd hui des
quatre avec échec puisque le fou à 8
ferait chez corroy qui est en h1 et la
dame serait perdu il peut il donc ici
supposons par exemple qui essaient 5
voilà des quatre échecs au roi un échec
au roi et la dame au coderpa grisons
prend la dame à la terrible donc ici
c'est la menace dans cette position on
menace qu'il prend 1,4 suivi deux des
cinq problèmes donc cette femme on
rapatrie s'en fout voilà il se rapproche
du roi fou prend fou on va quoi prend
hélas hélas l'échec en baisse est très
fort cet échec petit échec
pourquoi bien parce que ça amène la dame
sur une case où elle contrôle très bien
mais qu'à cela vous choque détiendra
l'ange important si on veut pousser ces
d'une opération sur les cases noires
sont savent assez tranquille ya le fou
il ya la tour en plus derrière bon ça va
quoi or en géant il faut bien mettre le
roi quelque part et maintenant on
reprend tranquillement en d5
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est un pion de
plus pour les noirs et on ne voit pas de
solution pour éviter l' avance de ceux
qui ont gagné ici ses positionnements
perdu mais peut être bien évidemment ne
sais pas si c'est un statut puisque
c'est du semi rapides [ __ ] qu'on peut
faire des gaffes h4 un tacle cavaliers
chasse le québec le problème si ça fait
bien encore plus laurent blanc
dix ans et il est dans l'air voilà il
est plus à ça près voilà il est plus à
ça près voilà en cavale est aussi ça
c'est pas mal ça c'est ça c'est toujours
ça c'est super parce que lecavalier voit
la menace devenir salle cazelles 4 où il
est superbe parce qu'il est contrôlé par
un pion donc très fort une équipe de
quatre c'est celle là et il attaque les
cases pré durable du prêt de rois de
crâne nick donc il serait très très fort
ce qu'amélie c'est sur saône cavaliers
la kasparov quoi machiavélique
l'espérance qu'avait lieu 4 ça c'est la
ressource de panic attack l'option des
six
ouais et menaces fourchette surtout
cercil et noir jouent des cinq il ya
cavaliers des six attaques d'armé tour
tout à fait il faut donc jouer des
recettes défend l'option des six et en
même temps attaque le curage carte ouais
donc ça c'est sûr
la difficile pour les libyens très
difficilement qui trouve un coup ils
jouent g5 n'aurait pas mal mal il faut
venir sur l'exercice voilà et puis bon
là comme ça les pions sont protégés et
puis l'association prend leur âge si ce
à quoi notre cavalier f4 ça c'est bien
joué
voilà le calice viennent s'installer sur
la case maintenant les pions g5 qui est
attaqué winona ce nom le clan g5 n'est
pas attaqué puisqu'il est défendu encore
pratiquer le 4 avril et encore des
médécins une menace qu'un moment voilà
la menace est bien sûr d'être à 10,5 et
ici peut-être que va devenir a raté une
petite comptes qui aurait pu lui
permettre d'obtenir quelques chances
il n'a pas vu je pense qu'il n'a pas vu
le coup cavaliers fonction des six car
les promotions des six mois est pas mal
parce que l'oreille voilà l'idée c'est
que si on prend le cavalier avec la dame
dont on est obligé de pour lequel est
quasiment obligé puisqu'il ya s'attaque
la tour donc voilà dan franck et on y
voit là et là on voit que la dame
blanche en e3 on montre tout de suite
beaucoup voient pourtant inférieur car
est-ce que si le pion vient reprendre la
dame blanche viendra prendre la 3 8 qui
n'est pas né avec échec donc c'est donc
un clouage aux collèges et lycées
municipaux âge et après tout point f cab
on est bien ici
qu'est ce qu'on voit est bien c'est
qu'on va bloquer ce pion un pion aux
cinq sur la case aux quatre temps des
choix enlever ces quelques flèches
on va bloquer ce pion éventuellement sur
une case blanche en 1 4 ouais et ensuite
on peut essayer de tenir avec un roi
faible comme ça ouais on mais c'est très
très dur
les noirs sont mieux c'est évident des
très bonnes chances de bien pour les
noirs probablement gagnant mais ici on
peut encore espérer s'en sortir donc
dans cette position que les demi-heures
kramnik a vraisemblablement raté ce qui
prouve qu'il ya toujours des chansons ya
toujours des chances sur yon semi
rapides à mettre 60 rien
les oublis sont extrêmement fréquents la
preuve ses chroniques par exemple qui
s'ils ne voient pas kelly prend 10
donc là il a jugé prend 1,6 oui mais le
problème c'est que voilà après fou prend
voilà faut prendre
et là on me restait en l'état on
s'attaquait la dame par indirectement
savez tout à fait d'objets trois là
peter les coujoux bien très bien
dames 2 6 donc ils surent protège son
pion g6 protège ses six ils commencent à
rentrer c'est à recueillir des idées mal
à vous de saisir le tout contrôlé
quasiment il y avait la dame contrôle
des caisses blanche oui et puis quand il
veut il joue décidé l'intérieur les
menaces d sign que donc là c'est tout
simplement terminer rouages de a été
jouée des cinq assaillants fin et là on
voit cette majorité de plus encore la
faune saddam et on voit pas comment les
unes blanc maintenant le peuple arrêtés
il a pris fin dans les poussées comme
louis wind en général c'est ce qu'on dit
c'est les pions canton les avances ça
gagne quel et j5 fou pranger 5
évidemment si on prend hélas il ne faut
pas rater le dernier geste technique de
cette partie où on envie d'amener la
tour sur la colonne h
c'est à dire sur pour faire un échec
mais pour faire des chèques dévastateur
qui conjuguée avec lecavalier et la dame
faire un match rapide pour ça on ne joue
pas en manger cette sas qui serait la
gaffe ça serait pas grave puisque là on
se met dans le clouage du fou du fou
mais ça ne peut plus bouger
photo raymond caille et apprendre tout
simplement lequel on peut pas reprendre
le revoir en échec comme ça ce serait
une erreur donc ils trouvent le bon coup
l'auteur ou toujours c'est la tour qui
vient en cet or cette voie là c'est donc
pas le roi qui laisse passer les tours
mais la tour qui contourne le roi donc
c'était un bon moyen ici menace de venir
en rage cette voie la tour sete qui fera
échec celui de cavalia 3 qui fera
fourchette qui ramassera le tour et ce
sera terminé ce sera terminé pour ces
deux derniers essais de chroniques
hélas hélas coûte rankin des médecins qu
facile alors d'un 9,5 ça attaque la
force et 2 ça contrôler la casse et 8
qui empêche un échec
oui et en plus cette dame est super
mieux d'avoir un lieu classé quand le 6
et le contrôle à la callas terefe on est
en train de faire une cage pour le
revoilà et la tourache 7 va gagner la
partie
oui en plus la dame peut entrer en b1 en
général c'est matt à peu près dans l'est
dans les dix prochains coups sur la
meilleure défense des blancs bon c'est
un peu une évaluation d'ordinateurs mais
là il n'y a plus aucune solution pour
tenir
voilà c'est là c'est vraiment être à la
tourache 7 suivi de gains matériels très
très élevé faut donner la dame et en
image très vite oui hein sinon les maths
donc surprenant cette partie surprenant
pourquoi parce que dès l'ouverture on ne
comprend pas ce que font les blancs et
on ne comprend pas ce que font les noirs
c'est à dire que chacun des 2 sort ses
pièces d'une certaine façon qui est un
peu surprenante sur la distance quoi les
blancs prennent d'eux
open beaucoup d' espaces avec cette
fameuse et aux dons à roxy oui et puis
cette formation-là hérisson là avec les
pions qui sont en attente tranquille qui
empêche les blancs d'avancé et en fait
finalement les blancs perte parce qu'ils
avancent leurs pions peut-être aussi
oui mais alors je me rappelle une phrase
de youssef dorfman qui me et qui disait
quand les noirs veulent son hérisson
si vous n'arrivez pas à gagner en moins
de vingt coups vous allez perdre ah oui
ce qui veut dire qu'en fait les noirs
qui ont l'air de faire une formation qui
va être mauvaise sur le long terme
puisque nos très peu d'espacé pour
manoeuvrer elle est en fait de bonnes
selon en fait elle est bonne sur le long
terme il faut tout de suite les
pulvériser avant qu'ils aient réussi à
mettre leur pièce à leurs pions en
vérifiant dit qu'après les pics sont
bien informés ouais tout à fait donc ici
même l'a dit mercredi quand il est allé
blanc quelqu'un un spécialiste en
spécialiste du jeu je checke puisqu'il
est champion du monde n'a pas trouvé de
solution contre le hérisson et donc
c'est s'est fait tout simplement
démontré qu' il n'est pas imbattable
alors on va peut-être devoir une des
victoires de l'avenir l'un d'eux alors
stéphanie noguès dix minutes web est
imminent mais la position intéressante
comme décor à la partie mais on va
peut-être montré pression puisqu'il ne
reste justement de dix minutes
donc c'est intéressant donc je sais pas
laquelle
parce que rien à 2 2 je pense qu'il
vaudrait mieux montrer c'est louis
lahaye les blancs ouais c'est louis
lahaye les blancs puisque il a gagné
donc on va le rappeler une berlinoise
mais c'était plutôt suite à des fautes
d'hôpital les coûts alors que la
première partie du match était très bien
c'est la fameuse grünfeld alors je ne
sais pas si c'est celle là a lancé
pascal van tran nghi clicquot ça doit
être
c'est bon c'est ça ces scènes là donc on
va on va y revenir très vite
voilà donc réalisation difficile
aujourd'hui encore notre réalisateur
non nous de switcher rapidement quels
passages allons nous montrer
on va remontrer vite fait les premiers
coups non là c'est une brune feld on a
déjà commenté ça c'est kasparov entre la
crainte ni contre kasparov
ouais ouais voilà et chroniques rejoue
la même que contre kasparov
après ces cinq qui joue ce fait vous aux
trois dames à cinq dames d2 avec échange
de dames rapide way qui ont encaissé 6
tours c'est un emplacement pièce et là
évidemment pendant le direct de ce
fameux championnat du monde mémorable eh
bien nous avions proposé puis on prend
des 4 comprend des cartes et les changes
des dames en suivant une indication de
hoffman qui dit dans la dot fait qu'en
échange les dames ils s'en sortent
toujours
eh bien on va voir que c'est pas si ça
me joue des tours b 1 et avait tourné un
petit tour non c'est pas ça
non non c'est toucher 4 non c'était pas
ça je crois pas du tout reprendre les
sept nains hésitant ici c'est sûr c'est
pas tout à fait la même en fait c'était
pas ton soir prend des dogmes voilà donc
ici on est en finale et la toux des
blancs c'est ce pion pas céder le
problème des blancs c'est que le roi
pour l'instant et au centre oui petit
rock dessins qu'il faut l'avancé très
vite autour des 8 est maintenant 3e 1
jouée par kasparov avec les blancs quand
ils allaient blanc il ya une dizaine ou
une quinzaine d'années je me rappelle
c'est dans son livre bizarre ce coup
livre qu'on conseille à tout le monde
l'épreuve du temps de garry kasparov et
sa vie c'est ça 8,6 pour les noirs le
cistre casser le centre blanc en plus
des fans ces attaques lequel ces
attaques le cavalier aux la question est
l'objet de bouger tout de suite ça bouge
pas le fou enfin il vend aux cinq
cavaliers prend cavaliers fou prend et
chroniques un spécialiste de ces finales
à terre de fou qu'il joue extrêmement
bien il avait déjà battu joël lautier
dans quelque chose de similaire perd 4
sous des six roi f2 ça y est l'envoi est
à l'abri sa mort est donc ici on se dit
que les blancs sont très bien pourquoi
si des noirs jouent aux 6es bien bonjour
à tous et 4 mai dans l'avertissement
jour même des quatre fin aux 5 et 8 6
oui oui exactement
alors on va montrer aussi ce sas et papa
de aussi ça a pas l'air bon il y a eu 5
le football où nous devons tous en a
trois pour cent la créat accroc bord on
attaque dont ses trois fous des quatre
en attaque ont la taille jusqu'à ce
qu'ils s'en aillent en fuite voilà et là
on les plante des cyborgs et c'est net
avantage mans donc ici il ya un problème
c'est que et bien les blancs vont
développer leur pièce et non c'est pas
trop ce qu'ils font donc plus tard les
coujoux le coût de 5
bien vu par mal et maintenant kramnik
combine fous ces cinq bien jouer il faut
débloquer il faut laisser passer ce
option même ici c'est un sacrifice de
pions stéphane c'est un sacrifice de
plus il laisse le pian f4 oui s'adossa
tri fini ça je crois tu reprends tu en
profites 4 parce que là voilà il joue
avec trois attaquants le pion et les
noirs peuvent pas trop protégé parce que
s'il joue g5
c'est un sacrifice depuis - ouais même
si je joue j'essaie que c'est pas bon et
ils peuvent changer cinq edwards non ils
peuvent pas by retour ses sets mais
s'est passé c'est très compliqué ouais
fou 17
d'ailleurs ça va on va s'y retrouver un
peu puisque là les noirs votre tour
s'est vite sur quoi vladimir kramnik
récupère pas le pion puisque je ne peux
pas laisser ça c'est pas le but je me
fous des trois tours s'est vite torcéen
voilà il faut pas l'impression qu'ils
étaient obligés et maintenant j'ai 5
c'était donc un vrai cette fille
d'options maintenant maintenant il peut
jouer juste un missile avait joué avant
il ya eu un spectre s'était pas c'était
pas clair c'est pas clair tour c'est
cette voie la tour prends tout reprend
les noirs ont toujours en plus mais là
on s'aperçoit que leur position n'est
pas est pas bonne bah oui le tube s est
attaqué on va beaucoup me l'a menacée au
5 suite d'esi ses fans avec un pion qui
passe en x 4
ranger 4 et voilà c'est des droits
mondiaux oui c'est fort non mais c'est
très beau c'est une très belle d'une
finale très très bien joué par le
devenir chronique voilà on va passer
quelques couacs cheese et là maintenant
il récupère un viande bigard un master
pro b cette voie là tour 17
net avantage pour vladimir kramnik à
noter que ces échanges les tours ici ne
gagnera pas il faut pas changer les
tours il faut pas changer tout retour b4
le fou de peter l'écho est mal placé
food est un échec
on monte en rêve 5 on n'a pas peur ouais
il faut pas avoir peur parce que c'est
chaud là on remarque ici que laurent
blanc a plus qu'une seule cave la case
au 5 et qui pourrait bientôt ne plus la
voir
d'ailleurs après h théâtre f6 ça y est
si il est en échec il est mat quand même
mais bon
mais bon mais on ne voit pas trop
comment il pourrait être mis chaque
chronique a vu plus loin évidemment un
jeu projet 5h pranger 5
et là c'est le coup ici qui fait gagner
la partie il est extrêmement compliqué
on a très peu de temps pour le commenter
ces mais c'est si le grand coup de cette
partie c'est le coût de la partie alors
à noter qu'il faut pas tomber dans le
piège des femmes le mauvais coup serait
d'en prendre six cas là rebond qui a
l'air avec a l'air très bon
malheureusement il se heurte à coup j'ai
quatre matches ouais ce qui ce qui est
tout de suite demande qu il est pas bon
ce qui démontre que le coup n'était en
réalité est pas le meilleur c'est clair
il faut bien le dire donc ici il ya déjà
on se rappelle évidemment de choc entre
beddiaf ski qui s'était fait planter un
matin un coup dans une finale qu'il
allait gagner
ouais c'était incroyable et c'était du
même style e5
alors ça c'est curieux parce qu'alors
salah se pliant aux quatre fait le pion
à 5 et le bon évidemment le prix le pian
2 des scènes qui des blancs est en prise
on va démontrer les options sont en
prime à la baule intéresse évidemment
c'est évidemment que
ça va casser la structure des tournois
alors on va montrer comme pourtant des
cinq sapeurs en ligne sa paire en ligne
après tout en baies cet échec échec
alors là plusieurs possibilités roi
j'évite qui perd tout de suite à cause
de fous ces caps qui trouve la tour sous
la tour watch fuite qui alertent nabeul
roi et fuite par exemple ça perd très
vite après roy prend et fils mais la
smat jonas mater c'est très dur à parer
le pion à vence
ouais c'est terminé donc ici après
tomber cet échec faujour achicourt h6
forcée voilà on l'a bel a tout
simplement c'était femme incroyable le
couffo bien tranquille menace roi prend
pions m6 avec le mat en fils a du nerf
imparable alors et exemple si les noirs
faisait par exemple je prends par
exemple de chebli exemple on prend 2 5i
way ici il ya le courant aux six sata
clatot attaque la tour et menacent tous
rage sept matchs avec le roi c'est fou
on mate avec et le fou contrôle geste
c'est le roi qui fait menaces et ses
terrines oui donc ici bon c'est c'est
très compliqué locaux et 5
mais c'est fort nous en a dit le plus
possible tourcoing des cinq paires de
manière forcée donc il faut prendre le
volant est france voilà et la chronique
conclu roy prendre 5 avec un pion passé
au centre on va on va regarder là c'est
ça l'idée en fait tout simplement ces
[ __ ] de fabrication d donc là je
crois en francs
vous désirez noir essayer de créer omet
aussi un pion passé ils sont bien en
retard des six parce que plus on va vite
tour des huit on passe le fou pour
empêcher les échecs fouilles 5 ans +
empêche g4 oui donc ça contrôler tous
fous ses six plus tard les coûts
abandonne ses projets de pousser sont
plongés et la d7 le coup de massue
la menace c'est de jouer trois des six
ouais surtout prend 17
on perd tout de suite suite à ce flou
autour b737 qu'il tourne pas si le fou
moi là je ne peux pas bouger tout
simplement viré le roi derrière voilà
après dix-sept put a ring on joue tous
réduite et la chronique le termine avec
tour des quatre menaces dame
ouais et si la tour vient en débit tu es
bien m'a tout simplement des six on voit
aussi ses poteaux
oui on voit aussi trois des six et les
rails les deux gagnent et on gagne
facilement donc voilà une belle victoire
de chronique bien dans son style très
positionnait les matières les cours n'a
plus rejoué la dentelle quand je dis
vite à à voir comment on gagne ces
genres de finale parce que ça là on dit
que c'est facile mais bon même
en gagnant avec ce que l'on gagne le fou
finalement oui maintenant la dame
souffre au camp mais la gagner c'est
quand même la gagner mais ça mais bon à
ce niveau-là conseil diagonale le
scénario s'est passé hier heureusement
qu'il reste le pion à 2,1 sinon ça
serait nul sinon ce serait nous le tueur
fou contre tours et voilà il faut garder
le plus 1 2 6 options qui font la
différence
oui mais alors très vite stéphane
quelques nouvelles en bref wait du monde
thomas d'hastings qui vient de se
terminer le traditionnel tournoi de noël
woods dont tu avais terminé second je
crois une année second en 97 90 ans que
tu jouais bien il ya très longtemps
effectivement première manche j'avais
perdu contre sa de l'air qui a gagné le
tournoi après avec cet ennemi sur notre
un score impressionnant
et là c'est l'indien sachy kieran
krishnan inga le droit c'est un espoir
abbas est un espoir indien oui oui tout
à fait il a je crois qu'il ya 17 ans
extrêmement fort 2600 bientôt donc à la
suite d'un homme quoi il gagne avec 6
sur 9
bosco en premier tout seul de ce tournoi
g service vers l'asie un toutou les
futurs champions seront sûrement
asiatiques les futurs champions seront
sans doute asiatiques déjà un évidemment
mais c'est le seul pour l'instant dans
les vingt premiers mondiaux mais je
pense que d'ici on a surtout très peur
des chinois est les chinois les indiens
je crois que les miens
les indiens ça bouge déjà au niveau
féminin c'est à peu près bouclé si on
allait bouger dit polgar sillonnait la
meilleure chose du monde
donc voila sinon il ya un match donc de
un ordinateur john van der wiel il est
en train de battre rebelles le fameux
programme rebelles le forem anglaise où
il ya là bas bien il le bat bien de 1
pour l'instant c'est pas mal
à noter qu'il n'a jamais perdu deux
parties contre les ordinateurs jeune
trentenaire ville c'est un des rares
humains qui fait de la résistance 1 et
kramnik aussi qui font un travail qui
est très fort et gagne match l'écho
kramnik évidemment sinon à part ça il y
en aura beaucoup de tournois mais qu en
dise ici avec andy qui arrivent alors
des s'annonce assad et marquant sa
démarche lundi le 12 le 12 donc la
semaine prochaine et donc je pense qu'on
va faire une spéciale des coms et mais
pendant trois semaines on va être obligé
et non il ya également stéphane le match
ponomariov kornoi ouais il va également
être comme très intéressante pas assez
sympa mais je veux dire que ça vaut pas
avec anzhi comme ça vous avez laissé
derrière voilà donc on se donne rendez
vous très beau programme du mois de
janvier à la semaine prochaine pour
mécaniser début de ce tournoi
et puis après des spéciales avec des
images puisqu'on va aller en hollande
film et tout ça